[Music]
a lot of women in marvel comics canon
have used the name ms marvel but where
does kamala khan fit into all this and
why did the character's television show
change her power set this is the untold
truth of ms marvel
the first miss marvel was actually carol
danvers long before she traded in her
leotards for a flight suit she was
fighting for equal pay and military
respect in her 1977 self-titled solo
series the use of miz as opposed to mrs
or miss was purposefully aligned with
the contemporary feminist movement
celebration of the title as an
identifier of women unto themselves with
or without a man this was even more
explicit in the stories themselves
though fans today know her best as an
ace pilot who drinks hard and lives to
surpass her own records carol spent much
of the late 1970s as a glorious steinum
type breaking down barriers in
publishing and public discourse as the
editor of woman magazine originally
hired by the one and only j jonah
jameson as a replacement for the
allegedly strident former editor carol
kicked off her reign at woman by being
openly feminist and putting herself as
ms marvel on the cover though her tenure
at the magazine was ultimately brief its
legacy remains the 2012 issue of captain
marvel that debuted her new identity as
captain marvel found carol carrying from
one of her former woman colleagues
carol isn't the only woman to have
stepped into ms marvel's boots however
1986 saw a brand new miss marvel and the
character of sharon ventura and her path
was a strange one indeed as part of the
super-powered wrestling circuit sharon
took on the title of ms marvel to better
rope in fans yet all was not well the
unlimited class wrestling federation she
joined hooked its wrestlers on addictive
substances that boosted their strength
breaking free of the ucwf wasn't the end
of her woes however after joining the
fantastic four sharon was exposed to the
same cosmic rays that altered the famous
foursome transforming her from a live
beauty into an orange rock monster much
like the thing despite the change she
rallied becoming better known as she
thing than she ever was is ms marvel
not all who have called themselves ms
marvel have been eager to make the world
a better place one woman in particular
dr carlos sofian is an evil doer who
took on the name as part of the 2000th
dark avengers storyline sofin started
out as a psychologist who manipulates
one of her patients into handing over
the gem that gives him and subsequently
her fabulous powers sofin's abilities
much like carols come from cree
technology in the form of gravity
altering stone typically known as
moonstone she's responsible for acts
like needling her patients into
self-harm and murdering her own mother
though she has at times flirted with
goodness this got complicated when in
2009 she joined norman osborne's dark
avengers in the end carla went back to
being moonstone and another villainous
superia took up the mantle for a time
finally after years of marvel playing
musical capes with the ms marvel title
kamala khan arrived debuting in 2014's
ms marvel number one kamala was an
immediate sensation a young pakistani
american teenager from jersey city she's
a hardcore superhero fan girl and an
unstoppable believer in doing the right
thing readers loved her from the very
beginning as a kind-hearted whip-smart
utterly modern incarnation of the
classic marvel spirit there is one
attribute that defines kamala more than
any other however she is an absolutely
enormous nerd the kind of kid who is
more likely to put off homework for a
world of battlecraft raid than a late
night romance the sort of superhero who
tracks down a bad guy who might be
stalking his guild mates in her devotion
to nerdery kamala isn't just a
believable teen of today she's a
celebration of geeky girls everywhere
kamala's passion for superheroes and
fantasy doesn't just entertain her it
fuels her in her undying mission to
protect the world she loves one question
lingers however does kamala read the
fanfic others write about her
if there's one primary object of
kamala's fan girlishness it's her
predecessor carol danvers kamala is
utterly devoted to carol explicitly
having taken on the mantle of ms marvel
and a tribute to her idol the 2015 last
days storyline of the secret wars event
finally brought kamala and carol
together in preparation for an
apocalypse that was thankfully averted
after a brief explosion of excitement
kamala calmed down and the duo worked to
protect the frantic citizens of jersey
city
carroll left kamala with a pendant
emblazoned with her star and kamala's
lightning bolt that would alert her in
case of trouble the love and respect
between the two was sealed a reciprocal
relationship now that they had met
rather than a one-sided adoration it all
did not remain well between the two the
civil war ii event saw kamala split with
carol when the latter used the
pre-cognitive abilities of an inhuman
named ulysses to administer brutal
justice when ulysses predicted a violent
attack from kamala's classmate josh
kamala went to his home and found a
confused young man with only the
possibility of violence within him
unable to punish people for actions they
had not taken kamala split with her idol
and everything she then stood for
reviews have been strong for kamala's
series ever since the beginning but
critical adoration doesn't always
translate into success so goes for many
critical darlings they reap a bounty of
gushing praise yet struggled to make any
actual money fortunately this has not
been the case for ms marvel since the
very beginning of her solo series kamala
has been as bankable as she has been
beloved a stone cold success story that
moves books off shelves at a steady clip
the first volume of ms marvel entitled
no normal collected the first five
issues of the series and became the
best-selling graphic novel of october
2014 the month it debuted in today's
book market kamal is up against some
stiff competition publishers everywhere
know that kids are hungry for comics but
kamala has bested them all remaining a
strong seller whose new volumes
regularly debut on the new york times
bestseller list
secret identities are the bread and
butter of superhero stories no one can
know spider-man's everyday life as peter
parker unless they target his loved ones
bruce wayne keeps his life as
internationally renowned playboy
decidedly separate from his nighttime
chaunce across the rooftops of gotham
city superman manages to fool the public
with a sturdy set of eyeglasses and a
pleasantly unassuming midwestern effect
exactly how would you know that kent
um
uh uh well just a first impression
kamala tried this for a while and she
managed to succeed for a good long time
say for her best friend bruno who's been
helping her in her mission from the
beginning but when the end of the world
was nigh during the last day story arc
kamala told her mother about her life as
ms marvel only to discover that her
mother already knew as she told her
shocked daughter muniba khan is proud to
have raised a righteous child and though
she worries about the danger kamala is
so frequently put in she supports
kamala's choices after this revelation
the dominoes quickly fell and now both
of kamala's parents know about her
superheroic side job
kamala is a nerd a superhero a capable
student and a fairly impressive ad-hoc
costume designer but before she is any
of those impressive things she is a
teenager and there's nothing that
defines a teenage experience quite like
first love bruno corelli is kamala's
love interest but their path has hardly
run smooth a brilliant young scientist
he and kamala met his young children
grew up together and now attend kohl's
academic high school when they're not
combining bruno's brains with kamala's
shape-shifting to take down all who
threaten jersey city
bruno obviously besotted with his best
friend from the beginning struggles to
admit his feelings and ends up dating
another girl mike while kamala explores
her interest in boys she's met among the
cape and cowell set what lies between
them was brutally battered when bruno
was permanently disabled in an explosion
during the civil war ii storyline still
reeling he traveled to wakanda to study
as a scholarship student and put some
much needed space between him and the
girl he can't quite seem to stop loving
well one issue saw bruno peering into
one of many possible futures in which he
and kamala mary hope springs eternal
especially for lovelorn teenagers
kamala's been around for less than 10
years an eye blink in superhero time
compared to characters like neymar and
the human torch who hail from 1939 yet
those years have contained an absolutely
dizzy number of team-ups crossovers and
partnerships uniquely for such a new
character kamala tends to set the tone
for her adventures alongside older more
established heroes when she fights
alongside wolverine they prowl the
sewers discuss the most popular
superhero fanfics and cross the canal
with the teen wonder carrying the
formidable x-men on piggyback in a
moment of admiration wolverine even
stops himself from cursing in front of
kamala later kamala crossed paths with
loki who crashes her high school's
valentine's dance did cosmic hijinks
ensue well not really the god of
mischief spiked the punch with asgardian
truth serum and failed to get bruno to
confess his feelings then as ends of the
marvel universe beware if you're on
kamala's turf you will end up playing by
her rules
kamal has changed the world more than a
few times at this point but it's not
just her fictional realm that's been
affected by her stalwart courage and
confidence it's our very own real world
too
first of course there were the ripples
caused by the announcement of her
imminent arrival in the marvel universe
commentators celebrated such a fresh new
face and hailed her as a win for
representation of marginalized people
this praise escalated steadily as her
comics continued to garner sterling
reviews and strong sales culminating in
a visit to the white house in 2016. they
are at a reception for women's history
month marvel editor sana amino presented
president obama with a copy of ms marvel
vol 1 and spoke to kamala's significance
within the modern world despite the
character's relatively recent creation
it's clear that she's already made a big
splash even before her disney plush show
language is a fluid thing it was only a
scamp few decades ago after all that
terms like googling and blogosphere
would have gotten someone blank stares
comic books have been a part of this
ever-changing tradition for quite a
while the word superhero itself is only
a little over a century old having
started with the scarlet pimpernell and
coming into full flower with the advent
of the golden age of comics
nowadays autocorrect knows words like
kryptonite and the average man on the
street knows what a thought bubble is
much as she's irrevocably changed the
marvel universe kamala has already
impacted the world of language in 2018
miriam webster added the word embigin to
its dictionary declaring it a real word
though a 1996 episode of the simpsons
was the first to coin the phrase
kamala's use of it to describe her
powers was likely part of its path to
respect indicated especially by
merriam-webster's tweet linking the word
to a gif of kamala the linguistic
authority defines it as a transitive
verb meaning to make bigger or more
expansive and as informal and humorous
and biggens
never heard that word before i moved to
springfield i don't know why it's a
perfectly cromulent word
as a huge fan of superheroes in general
there's no doubt that kamala khan has
enjoyed the opportunity she's had to
work with earth's costumed greats
interestingly some of her most notable
team-ups have been with a marvel legend
who started out as an anxious yet
determined teenage crime fighter himself
spider-man ms marvel and spidey first
officially teamed up in amazing
spider-man vol 3 number 7 to stop cree
scientist dr minerva from harnessing the
powers of a genetically enhanced baby to
build an army of kree super soldiers
kamala arrives on the scene first but is
easily outmaneuvered by the blue-skinned
supervillain fortunately spider-man
arrives just in time to lend the
fledgling superhero a hand and like any
true fan girl would kamala promptly
geeks out the prospect of being in a
spider-man team-up immediately
bombarding the web slinger with
questions about his dating history with
danvers after their adventure spider-man
tells kamala that she reminds him of how
he was when he was younger and reassures
her that she's doing just fine a
significant development in their
relationship takes place in the first
arc of marvel team up volume 4 when a
science demonstration gone awry caused
the spider-man and ms marvel to
temporarily switch bodies they
subsequently learn each other's secret
identities and develop mutual trust and
respect as they figure out how to return
to their own bodies
i'm not trying to be rebellious and i'm
trying to protect you from yourself
one can imagine that for a big superhero
fan becoming a superhero would be the
greatest thing ever the only thing
better than that would be to become a
superhero and earn membership to the
super team of super teams the avengers
for kamala khan that's exactly what
happened she and fellow young heroes
spider-man and nova joined the ranks of
the avengers alongside veterans like
captain america thor and the vision
unfortunately this dream was not meant
to last for the three costumed teenagers
but what followed was arguably an even
bigger highlight for their collective
careers in 2016's champions volume 2
number 1 we see part of the aftermath of
the second superhuman civil war already
disillusioned by the actions of her idol
captain marvel her frustration with the
adult superhero community reached its
peak during a mission wanting to be more
proactive in fixing the damage that
their superpowered brawls tend to cause
ms marvel quits the team after captain
america shoots down her suggestion to
fix the train tracks they've just
wrecked she stops her superhero
activities for a few days but eventually
reaches out to nova and spider-man with
an idea a team of newer heroes who will
fix everything their more experienced
peers broke during their dumb war soon
the hulk vibvision and a time traveling
cyclops joined the newly formed
champions under her leadership
the idea of individuals with superpowers
dressing up to fight evil has long been
a sore point in the marvel universe
despite the countless times they've
saved the world and even the universe
with their actions it tends to become an
even bigger problem when the discussion
shifts to the idea of inexperienced
young superheroes with no formal
training the champions especially ms
marvel found themselves at the center of
this issue and 2020s outlawed volume one
number one a standoff at cole's academic
high school involving the super team
renders the stretchy heroine
hospitalized in her civilian identity
and also leads to the passing of an
underage superhero ban in their effort
to protect a climate activist from an
attack by the roxon energy corporation
an unfortunate incident involving viv
vision and the new power man
accidentally causes a building to
collapse while still out of costume
kamala protects the activist with her
body but is rendered comatose this
prompts senator jeffrey patrick to pass
the underage superhuman welfare act
which was named kamala's law to honor
her the champions resist choosing to
fight for their right to operate as
superheroes eventually kamala's law is
repealed and the true villains revealed
thanks to their efforts
kamala khan is typically hailed as a
groundbreaking superhero in the media as
the first muslim character in marvel
comics to star in a self-titled book
however researchers at the london school
of economics and political sciences
middle east center have raised some
valid questions is ms marvel truly
assigned a positive social change or
simply a marketing stunt more
importantly does the character have any
real cross-cultural impact on how the
public perceives identity and talking to
participants from beirut london and
singapore the authors found that
marvel's move to greater diversity with
the introduction of kamala khan was
generally interpreted in two ways some
see it as a means of building better
cultural understanding and breaking down
majority minority tensions while others
think that it's nothing more than a
tokenistic gesture by a multi-billion
dollar entertainment company first off i
just want to say
i get it
it's undeniable that the young ms marvel
does to a significant degree represent a
welcome change in the western
entertainment landscape when it comes to
non-stereotypical representation of
different cultures redefine notes the
obvious similarities between kamala and
peter parker with both of them being
portrayed as regular middle class urban
teenagers saving the day in kamala's
case her being a muslim is not used to
define the core of her character nor is
it portrayed as an obstacle that
prevents her from becoming the best
version of herself regardless of
marvel's motives the push towards
diversity is a welcome one
while the formal announcement of kamala
khan becoming a part of the mcu was
certainly pleasant news to her many fans
there's one core aspect of her character
that got changed in her transition from
the page to the screen in the comics
kamala's dormant and human abilities are
unlocked following her exposure to the
terrigen mists she has both stretching
abilities akin to mr fantastics and
size-changing powers like ant-man in
addition she is a shape-shifter with a
limited healing factor on the other hand
her live-action counterpart possesses
thought-based light construct powers
which she discovered after wearing an
old bangle belonging to her family this
is so cool is this not nice
why did the creators of the disney plus
show decide to alter miss marvel's power
set and origin story so drastically in
an interview with decider the show's
head writer stated that in the interest
of efficient storytelling they left out
elements involving the terrigen mists
and the inhumans in favor of giving
kamala a streamlined origin regardless
fans are sure to be excited to see the
character making her way into the mcu
whether she's in beginning or not
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you